31 years ago at this moment I was still
on chairman square so the martial law
truce and that time have come from all
corners of Beijing it was an invasion of
almost a quarter million troops with
tanks machine guns at this moment it was
bit quieter before the priest asked
family out of TMS Square in the morning
and for those who don't remember
literally the tanks rolled over the
students that were protesting there yes
that happened a few hours later after
the students left chairman square we
were going Bank Weist
along Shanghai Street that the direction
of the college campus and a few tanks
twist and attacked from behind and first
send out poisonous gas pumps and then
just ruins through the students at least
about a dozen people died until today we
don't really have a full account and one
of the people who lost his life is the
function my friend he was trying to save
another girl student when he saw the
tanks coming but he lost his leg while
pushing the girl over to a safer place
so he is the only life survivor
now who is willing to testify most of
the others were injured or completely
silenced
now even though some of them as I know
leave now outside of China they are
still afraid to talk about it these
survivors of the tank attack that's a
kind of horror people still living in
today when it comes to the memory of 331
years ago
I was later funky sorry sorry sir I
interrupted you I just wanted to ask you
what it was like to watch the protests
that we have seen in Hong Kong over
previous months given what you went
through three decades ago to me it was
very familiar yeah to see millions of
people in the took to the streets last
year the whole process for most of the
youngsters today in Hong Kong their
political awakening was from coming
through the tendon region which happen
every year it's very familiar
I mean Hong Kong has been the key reason
to keep the tendon memory lives and now
it's all in freedom it's under threat
from the national security law yeah you
know what it's an absolute privilege to
speak to you sir I'm so pleased that you
could find the time to talk to us on
today of all days do keep well thank you
for taking the time thank you for having
me it's my duty and honor as a survivor